I also want to say to the Lord wilders
yes you may like Venlo and safe but I don't
what on the temperature
according to the latest channel report
if we don't put 1 scoop on top
goes through 3 degrees
and the Netherlands is 1 vulnerable country
sir GO away
and if we lead the way in this
not only reduce our vulnerability
then we also make the Netherlands 1 country that leads
in this battle
that means our economy will be strengthened
innovation is strengthened
that all these young people
Have 1 job in 1 sector that is leading in the world
and the wind energy
the solar energy at heat pumps
with all the new technologies that are coming
that is the future of the Netherlands
counterparts but you know that if you are different
okay quite applause
you know if you are going to talk differently
that your argument does not get stronger
I talk to you like I want mister wilders
but good too
but you know you speak I believe 7 languages
but at least not the language of the people
because what the people want
what the people want
is just that they can afford their groceries
and you now give Ben in the word
you spend capital
yes while also with much less chances
I am not saying that nothing should be done
I SAY you should spend that money well
there are even bigger problems
in the coming years then the climate you
can once again address the consequences
and it does not come from oasis
you are nothing at all
if we take good care of that costs then that is possible
the people together
lack of climate policy
are many times higher than the costs of climate policy
and who pays for that
those are the ordinary Dutch
the ordinary Dutchman